des cochons au pays de la charolaise
dans le sud du morvan l'élevage porcin
était devenue confidentielle au fil des
années mais depuis un an
anthony boulez a fait le pari de se
lancer dans cette activité en complément
de ces 60 vaches allaitantes la somme de
travail par jour reste très modeste on
n'a pas de gros investissements à faire
par rapport aux élevages de bovins dans
bâtiment matériels donc a pas une grosse
grosse prise de risque d'avoir une autre
production ça peut ramener un complément
de revenus supplémentaires les porcelets
arrive par l'eau d'une cinquantaine
avant d'être élevés en plein air pendant
plus de cinq mois sur l'exploitation
c'est le fournisseur d'aliments qui
organise la filière permet aux éleveurs
de ne pas avancer de trésorerie et leur
garantit un revenu par animal
indépendant des cours de la viande on
leur apporte un système où tout est
compris donc en se chargent de
d'apporter les porcelets le naisseur
amman et porcelaine ou livre l'aliment
est derrière les éleveurs vont toucher
la prestation une fois que les animaux
premier à l'abattoir aujourd'hui on leur
assure un minimum de 25 euros a garanti
ça paraît complètement dérisoire mais
aujourd'hui on a dix minutes disque
admis du travail par jour et entre
aujourd'hui en garantie et 25 euros mais
en général les adore toucher un petit
peu plus quoi entre 30 30 et 40 euros ne
fait levage font déjà partie du
dispositif avec l'objectif de développer
la filière car sous forme de jambon de
l'onj ou de produits dérivés la viande
de porc de plein air du morvan a trouvé
son public dès sa commercialisation
début 2019 et ne l'a pas encore plein
air du morvan elle était très goûteuse
il ya bien longtemps
une viande aussi goûteuses mon claude
gillot y est passé elle est beaucoup
plus goûteuse aussi la texture de la
viande est plus tendre on sait d'où elle
vient
depuis un an près de 700 porcs ont été
élevés dans le morvan
ici les cochons ne sont pas destinés à
remplacer les vaches
mais si la production se développe il
pourrait devenir une solution de
complément intéressante pour les
agriculteurs